good morning india
has become the latest country to be
added to the uk's travel red list
meaning anyone arriving from there has
to quarantine
in a government-approved hotel the
country now finds itself
as the new epicenter of the global
pandemic with a record number of cases
and deaths
being recorded for a second day and the
discovery of a new variant
milena vasilinovich has been meeting
some of those affected
by the latest travel ban these were the
last passengers to land in the uk from
india
ahead of new travel restrictions and the
last to avoid paying for costly hotel
quarantine
this family were back from seeing
relatives in delhi and were relieved
they managed to change their tickets at
the last minute
i think we will be having a quarantine
at home
that is the best part and i'm having a
child with autism
so it's better that he stays at home
with us and can have all these food
preferences at home
how did you end up back in india but
jetel zala who's doing her masters in
scotland was not so lucky
she's visiting family in india and
couldn't get a flight back in time
i tried calling the airlines but there
was i mean i couldn't connect to them
because definitely they were close
then i tried making an international
calls i started calling my friends who
are already in the uk
but there was no changes the flights
were as it is
but it was really uh disturbed
disturbing news for me like i was really
sad that i can't go back
and i don't know when i can enter the
country restrictions are disrupting
businesses too
restaurant owner ranjid mathrani says
most of his highly trained indian chefs
went home during the uk lockdown
and now they're stuck which could
jeopardize his plans for reopening
here we are after five and a half months
on lockdown
losing vast amounts of money looking
forward to limping back to normality
in the first place and we are going to
be
stuck with the probability and
possibility of being unable
to open except probably on a very
restricted basis
in some of our key fine dining
restaurants the uk has
deep historical and cultural links with
india so putting it on the red list was
a difficult decision the government said
but some scientists think that it should
have happened sooner
because of a surge in cases in the
country and a concerning new variant
over 130 cases of the indian variant
which
could be more resistant to vaccines are
already in the uk
we've seen cases increasing in india for
several weeks now
and it would have been prudent i think
to have put injury on the red list
earlier
it's obviously a tough decision because
there's a lot of communication travel
between india and the uk
but i think it would have been the right
thing to do a few weeks ago
with india now the epicenter of the
pandemic it will likely be
some time before these tough new
restrictions can be eased
milena vaselinovich sky news
well the travel restrictions come into
force as india faces rising numbers of
kovid-19 cases and deaths
in the latest 24 hours 332
730 people in india have been diagnosed
with
covid19 that's the highest daily rise
in covet cases anywhere in the world
2263 people have died in the last day
bringing the total number of deaths to
nearly 187
000. well joining us uh
from the government this morning is the
digital and culture minister
caroline dynage good morning to you uh i
don't know if you saw all of that
report that we ran there but uh we heard
from professor virology at university of
leeds
saying that uh there should have been
the decision taken
to put india on the red list weeks ago
would you agree that really this should
have happened weeks ago it's too little
too late
no because you know we we do keep this
under review all the time we
we appreciate that people have to uh
travel for
for for business and that there are huge
links between ourselves and india
the situation in india has worsened
incredibly
uh an incredible amount over the last
few days as you say
uh you know the the figures uh uh
330 000 cases in the last day
is one of the highest in the world and
and that's why we took steps to add them
to
uh the red list it obviously takes a
couple of days for that to kick in
for the um operation forgive me but the
professor was saying clearly that this
should have happened
weeks ago well we take you know we take
advice from the
from the the health experts on this we
you know we don't really want to add
countries to the red list unnecessarily
but the priority is absolutely to
protect people in the uk we've worked so
hard
over the course of this pandemic the
lockdowns have been so tough for so many
people
that we don't want to take these steps
but we will take them if necessary there
are now
i think uh 40 countries on the red list
which uh
um you know shows our commitment to
keeping this country safe
and the delay had nothing to do with the
prime minister's trade visit to india
the prime minister didn't go to india
did he no i i know but
he he cancelled the the trip to india um
latterly last year cancellation
no i mean it's all it's all kept under
review by public health experts they
look at the rise of cases we're you know
we're confident that
uh the the um the vaccines we have
will uh will deal with this variant we
haven't got any proof that they don't
but we've just still got to be err on
the side of caution
and and take these steps when they're
necessary to do it
you'll appreciate that people will be
very worried especially as the
the variant seems to be in this country
now um does the government know how many
planes
and passengers landed from india this
week
i don't i don't know that i'm a culture
minister but
um there will be a there will be a
record of that and of course the
uh you know we have one of the most um
some of the toughest measures in place
on our borders in the world with them
with the you know three-part testing
system and uh
and all the home quarantining that's
that's necessary and of course
the uh the hotel quarantine as well now
for those that are coming back from
india to um who live here so uh you know
this is um this is all just part of the
huge efforts that we've been putting in
place
right across this period to to really um
make sure that people are kept safe and
that we keep these variants out of the
uk
i just want to ask you about the uh
greenfield affair we know that david
cameron personally lobbied the
treasury's most senior civil servant uh
emails to the bank of england we now
hear
this morning um is it right that a
former
prime minister should take advantage of
his position
to secure financial gain for the company
that he was working for
obviously this is of concern the prime
minister has
commissioned an independent review to
look at the uh supply chain con
finance you know how contracts were
secured how business
representatives engaged with government
and it will look at
a whole range of issues it's gonna have
maximum possible access to all the
information that we need and we'll
engage with all those involved
um at the time when decisions were made
it's it's the review's underway so i
don't really want to
pre-empt do you feel do you feel
comfortable though with a former prime
minister taking advantage of his
his previous role in this way are you
comfortable with it personally
well i mean so far uh it it's so fun
we don't see any evidence that uh the
rules have been
broken but we just that you know that's
why this uh
this independent review has been
commissioned by the prime minister to
look into this very carefully because
clearly that would be a huge concern
uh nigel boardman's leading this review
it's going to conclude
uh by the end of june and i don't want
to preempt its findings but
uh you know we're going to look very
very carefully at this
but are you uncomfortable with the whole
situation
well that you know there are very strict
rules that govern ex-ministers
including ex-prime ministers uh and uh
you know the rules that that need to be
followed and we just need to make sure
that that there hasn't been any breach
of those
uh questing said on this show yesterday
that uh he gets calls from businesses
and constituents
all the time and it's perfectly uh
normal
um can you tell us who has access to to
your
personal mobile uh well i
i mean i'm not i can't off the top of my
head i'd have to look at that
and look at my mobile phone it's not
something one tends to give out
willy-nilly um
but you know we do as as ministers we
meet
business people in my my line of work
clearly i meet lots of people in
the digital world i'm minister for
digital and culture so you know those
are the two areas where
i would meet an awful lot of people but
also you know charities trade unions uh
other uh other bodies you know so
we meet people all the time but we're
according to you do you have a record of
this at all are records kept
yeah i mean i i don't tend to massively
um interact with people uh
by a text message but there are very
clear rules about what happens if you do
ever get approached you know you pass it
on to your private office and and
everything goes through the normal civil
service channels you don't we don't do
business
via a whatsapp or text message um and
also another story this morning is is
how leaky downing street is um
dominic cummings being blamed for
various leaks by the the prime minister
um what's your view on that uh do you
believe that he was responsible
absolutely no idea i know that like the
cabinet office are looking into
a leak inquiry at the moment but i know
that you wouldn't expect me to comment
on that
well i wouldn't have asked if i didn't
expect you to comment let's move on to
um uefa not letting countries
host euro 21 matches if they can't uh
guarantee
25 of capacity which means matches will
fall
to uh other um stadia are you
ready are we prepared to take on those
extra matches
yeah we we've been working really hard
as you know we've been running a series
of of
pilots they include a whole a whole
number of uh footballing pirates in fact
the caribou cup final this weekend
man city b spurs uh we'll see 8 000
people at wembley and it's all about
making sure that we
are um ready that we've we've looked at
the risks and indeed the mitigations for
those risks when
when the time comes for the next stage
of the roadmap to reopen
uh and just staying with football um we
know that edward wood executive vice
chairman of manchester united he held a
formal
meeting with number 10 chief of staff on
wednesday just before the the whole
debacle with the european
super league before it was launched uh
he then met the prime minister on his
way out
can you tell us if the the super league
was discussed
well according to both sides uh the epl
was not discussed of course it you know
it
does seem remarkable that he didn't
think to mention
it before the bombshell was was dropped
over there
over the weekend and i think to me that
probably explains the reaction from the
prime minister and the secretary of
state who are clearly really
shocked and horrified as the
announcement came out over over sunday i
was in the department of digital culture
media and sport on
uh on monday morning and there was a
palpable sense of dismay about how
fans views had been just ridden over uh
for this decision and a real
uh a real determination to to make sure
that this wouldn't happen
um on the seven million being uh
announced for
british film uh we know that films calls
tens of
of millions of pounds if if not more um
it doesn't see
an awful lot well it's a pilot i mean
you know we we have if you look we've
got the um the the oscars
this weekend and there's a once again a
huge raft of great
british talent both in front of and
behind the camera who are up for awards
um and and so you know we know that we
punch above our weight
on this on a global global scale this
money is a pilot it's supporting
independent uk film and screen
to export to markets around the world
it's about
helping them uh with business
development and co-production and
international distribution
and really about bringing further
recognition to
world-renowned british film industry we
it's a massive contributor the creative
industries to our uh
to our british economy and we know that
it can do more and we want to see it
flourish and
that's why we've um despite the
pressures of a global pandemic and the
pressures on
finance that we've managed to secure the
seven million fund to invest
in our tv and uh screen and film
industries to
really see what more we can do to help
them uh
reach out to a wider global audience we
know that there's huge appetite
for the british storytelling uh here in
the uk
danish thank you very much for speaking
to us this morning
thank you well our political
correspondent kate mccann
was uh listening as ever to that uh
interview and what did you make of what
she had to say
just wouldn't um admit that perhaps
india should have been put on
the red list a lot sooner i think that's
difficult i mean there is a process
behind
these decisions and they do tend to have
a buffer period if you like so that
people can make arrangements but clearly
the numbers of cases in that country at
the moment
are of a concern and so is the variant
which the government is
investigating as are others around the
world but i think it was the
exchanges on green sill and government
lobbying that really struck me in that
conversation because you asked twice
actually whether caroline darnage was
comfortable
with how this is happening at the moment
and she just couldn't say yes to you in
fact she said
you know there are really strict rules
and it would be of concern if they
hadn't been followed that would be a
problem
she said to other things though that
really struck me in that conversation
she said
her number isn't something she tends to
give out willy-nilly now of course over
the last week that's something that the
prime minister has been accused of doing
giving it out to businesses
and allowing people to contact him and
she also said that if people do
text her in her role as a minister she
passes those communications on to civil
servants because those are the rules
we know that's not what happened in the
case of james tyson and boris johnson
and that's why we're still talking about
this issue
number 10 clearly suggesting that these
texts have been leaked by dominic
cummings that he's bitter about his time
in number 10 but actually the heart of
this
is all about access to senior members of
the government and clearly some
government ministers don't think it's
right
yes interesting we shall see the results
of the the various inquiries that are
ongoing kate thank you
still to come on the show delivering
justice at half our seventh will speak
to one of the subpost masters waiting to
hear if their convictions for stealing
money
will be quashed after the post office
i.t
scandal the welsh first minister mark
draper joins us at
quarter to eight to discuss plans to
ease the lockdown in wales
and at 8 20 we'll chat with one of the
mps who took part in an
historic vote last night classing
china's treatment of the uyghur people
as
genocide
some breaking news to bring you now and
government borrowing hit
303.1 billion
in the year ending march which is the
same as 14.5
of gross domestic product it's the
highest level since the end of the
second world war
according to the office for national
statistics
now let's take a look at some of the
other news for you this morning
two major studies of more than 370 000
people
show vaccines should be able to help
control the covid19 pandemic
the study suggests a single dose of
either the pfizer or
biontech or oxford astrazeneca vaccines
can
reduce the risk of getting coronavirus
by 65
the businessman bill gates has told sky
news the world
didn't prepare for this pandemic nearly
like we should have done
but that vaccines will help us get back
to some normality
speaking to skies jane secker the
microsoft co-founder said that global
corporation
had been boosted by western nations
coming together
to share resources well as the pandemic
struck
a little over a year ago there was a
realization that this was a global
problem
and that we needed to orca state
resources on a global basis
and so uh particularly the uk france and
germany
uh came together with other actors like
the who and our foundation and said okay
what are the vehicles we can use sepi
uh was there to do vaccine research
agave to buy vaccines global fund
uh for therapeutics including oxygen
and that's what act a is it's taking all
of that
additional resources and coordinating it
on a global basis
uh and so i'm you know it was super
valuable that we did that
uh of course you know because we didn't
prepare for this pandemic
uh nearly like we should have you know
we've been learning as we've been going
uh but you know i'd say the good news is
that
uh partly because of the act day efforts
partly because of us r d
money we have the vaccines and we can
see the
you know the end will come for this
pandemic
and you can watch the full interview
with bill gates this sunday on sophie
ridge on sunday jane secker will be
sitting in for sophie this week
the government will consider plans to
give football fans in england a greater
say into how their clubs are run
an official review will also examine
whether the existing tests for
new club owners and directors are fit
for purpose
the skies jeremiah walker joins us now
from the
newsroom uh morning to jeremiah so uh
exactly what sort of detail
do we have at the moment
well this is actually a very
wide-ranging review and
we'll look at three main areas the
financial sustainability of football
clubs the structure of
ownerships and crucially the fan
experience
now the conservative mp tracy crouch is
leading this review and she has said
it will take the necessary steps to
retain the game's integrity
competitiveness and most importantly the
bond that clubs have
with its supporters and the local
community now this review comes
in the wake of the european super league
debacle whereby this
the big six english clubs announced it
would join this league whereby they
could not be relegated
and that of course caused uproar from
politicians
from prince william and not least the
fans
and i think one of the really
interesting things that it revealed
was this chasm really between the
priorities of the fans
and the priorities of the often foreign
ownership
and because of this this review will
look at the german bundesliga model
whereby clubs cannot compete unless they
are majority
fan owned this is an idea that the
government is clearly very keen on
boris johnson mentioned it in prime
minister's questions this week but i
think there are real
significant question marks about how
exactly it could be
implemented this review has been brought
forward
and i think politically it's a very
important review for the government to
signal to fans that this is something
that we care about
the government have released a statement
this morning saying that football is in
our national dna
but it is clear that we need to closely
look at its future
thank you the uk
could host more euro 2020 football
matches this summer if other host cities
can't guarantee
allowing fans into the games uefa will
this morning discuss rescheduling some
matches
if cities like bilbao and dublin can't
allow fans into ground
and observe social distancing
rescuers in indonesia are searching for
a submarine that
disappeared two days ago with 53
crew members on board our southeast asia
correspondent shivan robbins joins me
now
siobhan um bring us up to date with what
has happened
and where we are now
this is such a tense moment in the
search for this submarine because there
are now
only around 12 hours of oxygen
left for the 53 crewmen on board that
submarine
the submarine disappeared on wednesday
morning it was taking part in this
training exercise
off the island of bali it asked for
permission to dive it was given
permission to dive and then from that
point
communication was lost and since then
there's been this huge
effort to try and locate what has
happened to it and where it is
so planes were sent up as well as ships
sent out to look for it and
some of the spotter planes quickly found
oil slicks on the water
it is possible that is linked to the
submarine so much of the searching has
been
carried out in that area around 60 miles
off the coast of bali
and there's been assistance from other
countries countries including singapore
malaysia the us australia india
all offering to support this huge uh
search and rescue effort which is now
including more than
uh 24 vessels as well as these spotter
planes
ships as well equipped with sonar to try
and locate
this submarine but there are real
concerns about the safety of those on
board not just for the fact that the
oxygen's running out but also that they
haven't been heard
from there has been no sign at all of it
since it disappeared
on wednesday now what has been located
is this
area of high magnetism below the surface
which is one of the areas that they're
focusing on
in the hope that that could be coming
from the submarine and then hopefully
they can try and
rescue those on board the other big risk
for those
who are stuck on that submarine is if it
has sunk too
deep because if it sinks um below around
600 700 meters then the water pressure
it's warned may simply become too strong
essentially for the outside of that
submarine to withstand so it could then
break up so a really
really difficult time for the family and
friends of the 53 on board who are
waiting for news
indeed very tense situation there shiva
for the moment thank you
u.s transport secretary pete butterjudge
has said investigators are still
gathering information about a fatal car
crash on saturday
in texas involving a tesla in which
local police say
no one was in the driver's seat there is
growing scrutiny over tesla's autopilot
system
which handles tasks allowing drivers to
temporarily take their hands off the
wheel
tesla says the feature requires active
driver supervision
but the us magazine consumer report says
it's been able to operate vehicles
without anyone in the driver's seat
the duke and duchess of cambridge have
marked prince louie's
third birthday by releasing a photograph
of their son
pictured on his first day of nursery
school
louis who is fifth in line to the throne
was pictured by his mum
as he rode his bike
happy birthday to him time now for a
look at the weather
with joe good morning to you you're
going to be bringing us sunshine aren't
you
i am indeed in fact it's saint george's
day
and it was 1984 that the record sunshine
was set
13.9 hours we had 13.8 yesterday
at ronald's way we could well break that
record today we'll just have to wait and
see
let's take a look at the weather details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there uh good morning to you we
can thank high pressure for the
wonderful weather that we're having at
the moment
but that high pressure is also forcing
this storm system in towards spain and
portugal and they're looking at a grim
few days with some very wet and windy
weather
for us it's quite breezy uh associated
with that storm over parts of the
southwest
also through channel coast southernmost
counties so feeling a little bit cooler
here but elsewhere
plenty of sunshine to come and
temperatures 16 to 19 degrees celsius
that's 66 degrees fahrenheit feel very
pleasant out of the winds
and to avoid the winds stay away from
the coasts because the onshore breezes
will make it cooler there through the
course of the day more in the way of
cloud over parts of scotland
very small risk of an isolated shower
but mostly most places staying dry
into this evening and overnight as well
the big difference with tomorrow is
we've got some misty murky low cloud up
towards the northeast which will take a
while to burn back
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on a sky news breakfast uh
we'll be meeting one of several
sub postmasters waiting to hear if her
conviction for stealing money will be
quashed
after the post office i t scandal
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the government is facing
further lobbying allegations following
revelations that former prime minister
david
cameron contacted the treasury and bank
of england on behalf of the finance firm
greensell
it comes as boris johnson faces fresh
criticism for texts to the businessman
sir james dyson earlier i asked digital
and culture minister caroline dynage if
it was too easy for big business to
access top
government officials we do
as as ministers we meet business people
in my
my line of work clearly i meet lots of
people in the digital
world i'm minister for digital and
culture so you know those are the two
areas where
i would meet an awful lot of people but
also you know charities trade unions
uh other uh other bodies you know so
we meet people all the time i mean i i
don't tend to massively um
interact with people by a text message
but there are very quickly rules about
what
what happens if you do ever get
approached you know you pass it on to
your private office and everything goes
through the normal civil service
channels you don't we don't do business
via a whatsapp or text message
carolyn danish there a group of 42
sub postmasters and postmistresses will
learn later today whether their
convictions for stealing money
will be quashed amid a post office i.t
scandal
they were imprisoned after the post
office installed the flawed horizon
computer system
some have now died and will never be
able to clear
their names one of the former post
office workers fighting to clear her
name
is sima misra and she joins me now
good morning to you now you're actually
in the car uh about to to head off
to to get to court this morning um
how are you feeling
i'm basically all feeling i'm nervous
and looking forward as well
but but but nervous why nervous
yeah because going to court i went to
court in 2010 to get justice that didn't
happen
uh fingers crossed today it will get
justice
tell us a bit of the the back story what
what actually happened to you when you
were
working in your role for the post office
what what happened
when they were money missing from the
system and i've been told i have to make
sure the tills are correct
so i have to put money from my own own
shop float to borrow money from the
friends and family
keep on putting the money in but never
got any money back and then they accused
me of stealing money
went to the court that you know like uh
hopefully i will get justice
but that didn't happen in 2010. and this
was a new it
system that that was brought in that you
had to to utilize
which you did raise concerns over
because as you say that
the books weren't balancing you you were
short on on a daily basis
true from the day one i was i was
screaming for help but
there was no support and you were
advised
to balance the books that you had to use
your own personal money
true so i mean what what extent how much
did you have to to put in to try and
cover what
what you thought was there was a an
error
oh my god do every day to start with it
was under 100 pounds
then i went on the individual deal it
was going around 100 and
it came to the point when i stopped even
counting the money i was just like
from the shop floor whatever we needed
next day for the shop running that was
going in the bank
rest without even counting i was just
putting into the post office
and because of your your concern that
this simply wasn't right you you
actually yourself called in
the auditors who who came in couldn't
find the floor
but but said that definitely there was a
shortage and
you might be suspended because of that
true they said uh mrs mishra we have so
many post office they're doing fine it's
just your post after having your issue
with
anytime you over 500 pound shot will
take your post office away
and then take us to to that point to you
actually being convicted
thank god i was pregnant as well and
that was the i still
i still hope that seems like a bad dream
i wake up and nothing like that happened
but
it's it's here now i was pregnant i had
i was sentenced to 15 months
that was the worst time of my life
i can't imagine what what that must have
felt like
being eight months pregnant being
sentenced
to a jail term for for 15 months uh
how did you feel i mean what what
appeals did you put out for help
i was eight weeks pregnant i was eight
eight weeks okay
not eight months yeah i was eight weeks
pregnant
it's nothing i thought like you know
that's it that's the end of it
luckily if i would have been pregnant i
would have killed myself that's for sure
it got that bad yeah i was so scared of
a baby help
and you know anything can happen i lost
my faith
and it must have had a terrible impact
obviously not not only on yourself but
but uh
the rest of your family true yeah
whole family suffered my eldest and
husband everybody
and what emotionally physically yes
you're saying emotionally and physically
and also it it's been difficult for you
to find future work
yeah it's been nearly 10 years i'm
unable to work
i applied so many places applied to be
an uber driver that was refused because
of my conviction
so what are you hoping for today
hoping to get justice you know you're
going to be long delayed but
at least it will you know you will get a
justice
and the best result for you would mean
what
best result for me conviction like
overturn on limb one and limb two
and you've been fighting to to clear
your name
um obviously so that you can work that
that really is the main issue for you
that you can earn
a livelihood and not be prevented from
doing that because of this hanging over
you
and my dignity as well you know it's
been like uh
i haven't been i've been like hiding
myself you know like
uh because of the conviction conviction
of overhanging on my
over my head i couldn't even like travel
like everything everything it means a
lot
it has been described as one of the uk's
biggest miscarriages of
of justice um would you
agree with that because obviously this
is your case we're talking about but but
there are others
in similar situations some of us some of
them no longer
with us true definitely this is the
biggest
um i still don't believe it this is
happening and how they could
get it done by this so many years since
what what would you want to say to the
the post office today
i hope they learn from it you know like
they should but once again they have to
make sure that nothing like this happen
again
it's all it's all was in their control
still in the control as well
seymour mr thank you so much for
speaking to us uh
safe journey and uh we hope the outcome
is as you would wish
thank you so much thank you very much
now with uh under two weeks to go until
polling day
canvassing for the local elections is in
full swing
but the pandemic has made parties usual
ground game
far more difficult which could lead to
an uncertain outcome at the ballot box
kate mccann reports on a very different
year on the campaign trail
it's great to be out campaigning again
local elections can be an important
yardstick to know how political parties
are doing more generally but this year
campaigners have missed out on vital
weeks of knocking on doors to persuade
voters to back them
because we've not been able to go door
knocking because of the lockdown we've
been
doing a lot more telephoning but of
course you don't have every voters
telephone number
and a lot more online as well so people
may have seen things popping up on
facebook and those are better than
nothing but really there's
nothing that can replace the personal
interaction
between a candidate and a voter you know
that's what tells the candidate what
really matters and what they need to
focus on
those last weeks have made it much
harder for politicians to know who will
cross which box on the day
this is the reality of campaigning in a
pandemic instead of working from a
village hall campaigners are working out
of the backs of cars the
leaflets are stacked up and handed out
and everything is socially distanced
the pandemic has been really
unpredictable and it's made these local
elections unpredictable too
it's obviously the beginning everyone
was slightly nervous about knocking on
doors not knowing how
everyone would feel but actually i think
everyone's quite keen to have a chat
the pandemic has seen communities come
together and those independent groups
have realized they can run things pretty
well themselves
now many are standing for office adding
another element of uncertainty for
established parties
we have seen a number of different
independent groups but we are seeing
those independent groups
popping up across the country and it
will make it more complicated because
as i say these are very local elections
it's down to ward and division and you
start to
split votes in different directions
makes it really really unpredictable
others are more positive about their
prospects but still conceived
campaigning this time around hasn't felt
the same
people are really pleased to see us i
think in some cases we may be the first
people they've seen
uh this year since uh they last spoke to
a delivery driver so we're
we we've made their life slightly more
interesting and in terms of how you've
been able to run this campaign
i mean people who are involved in
politics will know that the big part of
campaigning is the social aspect and
you guys have lost that i mean how does
that feel this time well it would be
nice occasionally to get to the pub
after a canvassing session or indeed
even to go out and gaggle local
elections while not always the most
exciting political moment are really
important
this time around normal rules are out of
the window and campaigners are preparing
for surprises in a few weeks time
kate mccann sky news
time to take a look now at the day sport
with jackie
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
six premier clubs have agreed to be part
of a plan for a new european super
league
there's already enormous opposition to
the plan with uefa and the premier
league threatening
bans for clubs and players manchester
united
liverpool arsenal chelsea tottenham and
manchester city
are the clubs involved while barcelona
juventus
and real madrid are also understood to
be on board well the news has been
broken on the eve
of the planned uefa announcement for a
revamped champions league
well today's developments provoked a
furious response for our very own gary
neville have a listen to this
i mean i'm a manchester united fan and
i've been for 40 years of my life but
i'm disgusted
absolutely disgusted i'm disgusted with
manchester united and liverpool most i
mean liverpool they pretend
you'll never walk alone the people's
club the fans club
manchester united 100 years born out of
workers
around here and they're breaking away
into a league without competition
that they can't be relegated from it's
an absolute disgrace and
honestly we have to wrestle back the
power in this country
from the clubs at the top of this league
and that includes my club and i've been
calling for 12 months as part of another
group for an independent regulator to
bring checks and balances in place to
stop
this happening it's pure greed they're
imposters
they're imposters they're nothing to do
the owners of this club the owners of
liverpool the owners of chelsea the
owners of manchester city
they're nothing to do with football in
this country there are a hundred nod
years of history in this country from
fans
that have lived and loved these clubs
and they need protecting the fans need
protecting i benefit from football
hugely
i've made money out of football i invest
money into a football club now i'm not
against money in football
but the principles and ethos are fair
competition and the rights to play the
game so that
leicester win the league they go into
the champions league
manchester united aren't even in the
champions league arsenal aren't even in
the champions league watched him earlier
on today absolute shambles of a football
club at the moment
tottenham in the champions league and
they want a god-given right to be in
there
they're an absolute joke and honestly
the time has come now
independent regulators stop these clubs
having the power base
enough is enough let's be clear about
this what is the motivation
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
still to come on sky news breakfast i'll
hear from the welsh first minister
mark drakeford about why further
relaxations to the country's covert
restrictions
will be brought forward by two weeks
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling into a climate crisis
which cannot be avoided no one can
predict the impact that it's going to
have
this is really the moment of truth
expected to be hit very hard
indeed what can be done to reverse the
spiral
the daily climate show on sky news will
look for the answers
and we are desperate to welcome you this
summer so i i think yes
i think we will be ready here in spain
and and we also uh think that uh
things on on vaccination scheme on the
uk
i are going pretty well so i'm
hopefully we'll be seeing this summer
the restart
of holidays we
since the beginning of the of the
pandemic we've we've been trying to put
in place
different means to help a safe tourism
it is true that we've passed through
some
waves of of this pandemic this virus
but now i think we are ready because we
do have
vaccination vaccinations have changed
a huge deal from what we had last
summer so i believe that once we
reach to a mutual agreement and i have
to say that
we've been having constant
conversations with uk authorities
this certificate is going to give us and
it's going to ease
the the travelers and help tourism
uh from this amaron it is true
that safe tourism is key in this matter
we we want uh tourists
to to reach to spain
with all the guarantees with all the
means of
safety so we we
could be thinking on a corridor
spain is pushing hard on the european
commission
in terms of reaching agreements not only
between member states
but also with third countries third
parties
such as the uk we all believe not only
spain
other countries we all believe that the
uk
has has to have
proper treatment
and agreement and mutual recognition
with us with with uh
european members so we believe that if
if we reach this kind of agreements from
the
from the month of june we will be able
to have
a summer probably not as the one we had
in 2019
but obviously the restart of tourism
again
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body
can be damaged by air pollution
[Music]
the fine weather is going to stay with
us right the way through the weekend
this morning it's another cold and
frosty start light winds for many but it
is
breezy down towards the southwest and
we'll see gusts of 30 to 40 miles per
hour
through the course of the day
temperatures in the mid teens peaking at
around 18 possibly 19 degrees celsius
that will be 66 degrees fahrenheit and
air pollution is generally low
but we could find one or two pockets of
moderate levels particularly over
central and southern parts of scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
the welsh government has confirmed it
will bring forward further
relaxation to coronavirus restrictions
two weeks ahead of schedule
wales will now move to alert level three
by monday the third of may
meaning indoor activities for up to 15
adults will be
allowed well joining me now is the welsh
first minister
mark drakeford good morning to you and
just run us through what people will
be allowed to do assume some indoor
activities
indoor organized activities for children
indoor activities for
up to 15 adults we'll be able to resume
we'll reopen the rest of the tourism
industry
and we'll be able to allow a larger
number of people to meet
outdoors and indoors provided
always provided that the current good
state
of the coronavirus outbreak in wales
is maintained and we have the head room
to go on easing those restrictions
why do you think that now is the right
time why have you brought this forward
by
two weeks well we review our regulations
every three weeks so we've had that
three week cycle for
12 months now so i am reporting at the
end of the current three week cycle
the numbers of people suffering from
coronavirus in wales continues to fall
with the lowest incidence of coronavirus
anywhere in the united kingdom
and our vaccination program continues to
go from strength to strength
we've got the highest number of people
vaccinated in wales
of any part of the united kingdom all of
that has created some extra head room
for us to be able to bring forward some
of the easing of the restrictions that
we anticipated three weeks ago
our chief medical officer and our chief
scientific advisors
have given us the go ahead to move those
things forward
and that's what i'll be announcing today
have you seen any incident of the
indian variant and if so what is
specifically
being done to counter that we do have
examples of the indian variant here in
wales
uh it's a relatively small number and
all of them
are very carefully monitored by our
local public health teams
uh we don't think that there is any
reason for us to be alarmed at
the current number that we are aware of
of course
every day we review the situation
because there may be people who have
returned to the united kingdom more
recently
if they come from india there will be a
chance they have the indian variant
so the very careful work that our local
public health teams do
in keeping on top of the situation in
wales
that is what is allowing us to take the
steps we're taking today
but i will be saying to people in wales
that of course coronavirus is not over
those new variants that are appearing in
other parts of the world need
very careful watching and we will
continue in wales
to do things in a step-by-step way
with caution our watchword never going
beyond what the science tells us
it is safe to do in lifting restrictions
um of course it's a sensitive time with
the elections
um during an election period do you
think it's
appropriate that you should be making
these announcements rather than
the public health bodies well it's right
for me to do it because i
am the first minister and i go on being
the first minister during the election
period
i am responsible for the decisions that
the welsh government
makes and it's right i think that i am
answerable for those decisions and today
i'll be holding our normal press
conference
uh the coronavirus pandemic doesn't know
there's an election on
i will be there as the first minister
answering the questions explaining what
we are doing
and i'll continue to do that until there
is an election and the people of wales
make their decision about who they would
like to be in government beyond it
do you understand that the criticism
though that's been leveled against you
that it gives
you uh perhaps an unfair advantage
well i'm sure of this that uh if i had
to be announcing more difficult news
today
uh opposition parties would be demanding
that i was there
making that announcement i make the
announcement every three weeks i've had
to do it
on some very difficult days when the
news has not been good
i've made it at the end of three weeks
when the news has been better
and today i simply return to the podium
as i have every three weeks
to let people in wales know the
assessment of the current state of the
virus in wales
the decisions we're able to make on
their behalf or assessment of what can
happen in the future
and to remind people in wales that
coronavirus is by no means over
mark drake first minister of wells thank
you very much for speaking to us this
morning
thank you time now to take a look
at the weather for you joe is back still
smiling
so i'm sure it's still the sun will be
shining
it is indeed high pressure is going to
keep things very nicely settled over the
next few days plenty more sunshine to
come and then it gets a little less
settled
next week but let's take a look at the
details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
we've seen a very dry april so far and
as we approach
the end of it there's not a lot of
change in sight so high pressure keeping
things
beautifully dry clear a little bit
chilly at night we're still seeing
frosts this morning no exception
a little bit of mist and fog as well
over the western isles but in essence
we're looking at another lovely day
temperatures reaching around 17 to 19
degrees celsius that's a high of 66
degrees fahrenheit very pleasant inland
but down towards the southwest it will
be quite windy so feeling cold in that
wind it'll also feel a bit colder
along coastal areas where we have sea
breezes
the weather sponsored by qatar airways